say Trump runs four years okay okay and
the sentence goes behind them so he goes
in and they duke it out for five months
whatever the time six months five months
and then within two three months okay
guess what game it's yours perfect
they talk to each other just like Ted
Cruz lined up and Ted Cruz like let's go
let's roll Trump can flip real quick if
you're gonna get his back he'll flip
right so DeSantis comes and backs them
up and they run now watch during Trump's
second term if the Santa's got his back
100 percent
guess what Trump's going to do for
DeSantis Trump's going to be his number
one flag carrier and help him become
president and then DeSantis can have 12
years eight years which means it'll be
Trump DeSantis 12 years